muss ich das wirklich was lage heute
lasst einfach auf mich wirken heute wird
ich mach jetzt ein video okay ich sie
mir was sagen ja dann ehrlich informiert
würde würde ich meine videos einfach so
machen wie oberkörper frei war und mein
youtube kanal würde gelöscht werden weil
ich mir dieses tiefs ein junges chris
rodgers der bewährten style oder in der
u6 willkommen zu einem neuen video leute
ab jetzt werde in jedem video schaut aus
an euch geben jetzt durch wie wie macht
er ganz einfach geht einfach auf mein
kanal und mache die post notification
also klickt doch diese glocke und
klöppel an ich will meldungen von
erhalten und das gemacht habe
kommentierte einfach unter dem video ich
habe die notifications an gemacht ich
werde immer zufällig einer von den
personen aus wie möglich caches platte
die an gemacht hat und kommentiert hat
und geht den schauen in meinem video
also wenn dabei sein wollt dann seid
dabei okay leute zum heutigen video
jetzt gibst du freunden gesagt auftritt
okay immer wenn man irgendwas passt doch
egal war ist man lieber irgendwas main
post ein video man schreibt irgendwann
keine ahnung dort schreibt man auf
twitter ich weiß nicht renault muss
wegen kommentieren immer leute nicht mit
texten nicht mit irgendwelchen
botschaften sondern mit bildern von mir
und war mit verdammt weh taten bildern
die sie irgendwo her bekommen habe und
genau die schauen was heute an und nicht
gut merken was wir wirklich wilde von
mir habt ihr müsst ihr report dem was
läuft für weder von ihr habt da gibt's
wirklich kraft sagt zum beispiel dass
wir jetzt schon das allererste was wie
ein linker das vermitteln dieses foto
offensive ausgelaufen 80 irgendwie
dunkle gassen begegnen euch dieser typ
was will die machen schreibt die
kommission wird der youtuber die einfach
so immer für die machen ja immer alle
kugeln ich muss immer gut aussehen
session on point of in zu den bildern
immer so players menschen die mich oder
keine ahnung markt oder luca die macher
und einfach so hart über und selbst
wirst dich dann kommt solche bilder zu
steine danke recht unternehmen will mich
einstellen wenn so ein bisschen draußen
ist
richtig geile wird entscheidet das ist
im nordsee urlaub entstanden und war
auch eine ente die nennt man das war zu
der zeit wo ich noch lange haare hatte
und jan ludwig mit drauf und in der hand
halte ich acht kraft derzeit noch
richtig viel apfelsaft getrunken habe
das gefühl ich ein glas abgesagt was
auch wirklich einfach gedacht ist ein
bild gemacht wurde vierter lustiges buch
erlebt auf jeden fall wartet die zeiten
wo ich noch getragen habe und die sache
ist unseren top zu tragen
linda braucht man einfach verdammt lange
hart und manchmal hab ich mir einfach
gedacht du ihn schreiben ausleben ich
schalte auch ob jetzt cool aussehen oder
lustig aus der des weges den top
aufgemacht und dann kommen solche sachen
zustande
aber ich finde sie gar nicht so schlecht
denn ich tu dir dafür dass es meinen
gescheiten job hat ja dass man sinnvoll
geld verdienen kann und keine angst mein
ganzes leben lang erinnern wo es welche
unternehmen stehen leute einen solchen
bilder online sind ich habe mein leben
zerstört und an wann ich hab den fucking
softwares einfach so etwas noch mal
hallo wird
vorher haben wir dieses bild sollte
dieses video die einfahren
ja machen kurz auf die banken gebe dazu
muss die geschichte erzählen okay wir
waren amsterdam gekommen war gerade wir
haben sowieso mit max etwa die studios
deren die ohren ab der partie schon das
duo annette und ich weiß nicht wann ich
hatte so ein zweifel selbst getrunken so
wie ich immer machen patrick low carb
live verstärkt fitness leid und ich habe
in dem moment einfach gut läuft ich habe
in dem moment einfach gefühl ich dass er
so wie geil ist das mal eine fiktive
kostenlos getränke kostenloses essen die
leute hier sind sehr gut und ich habe
mich etwas so gefreut meinen kleinen
bruder dabei zu haben dass mir gedacht
habe so ich hab das ewig nicht mehr
gemacht werden ob ich jemals gemacht
habe
ich muss jetzt einfach mal einen kleinen
bruder kurs geben und der künstler aber
leute es gibt momente da fühlt man
einfach so dass man eine gewisse sache
machen muss und dann macht man einfach
nicht
dieses fehlt ihr alter schwede kurz die
story dazu das war mega mega lage her
das war mein achtzehnter der neues liter
geburtstag die wir gefeiert haben es ist
schon wirklich über zwei jahre her
manche und am bodensee besucht
das war so das einzige mal dass ich mich
überhaupt familie besucht hat meine
familie liebt mich auf jeden fall und
deswegen nicht morgens stellen wir haben
in der bude gefeiert ihr das seht und
haben einfach viel laden komplett
auseinandergenommen dinge passiert ist
kann sich und erzählen würde er wird von
mir und von anderen leuten schwer
beschädigen auch nicht woran wir sowieso
mega fit gefühlt vom abgesackt
wenn die vitamine für euren körper des
seelsorgers nicht völlig gefühlt aber
ich muss sagen allgemeiner form
weiterführen man liebt euch mal die
latte team uster als dass ich sie muss
ist das ding hier unter dem arm dieses
ding hier wird das ist dieser flügel und
der war mega und point damals als es
heute nicht so krass zu mir okay haben
wir dieses bild hier ich glaube dazu
muss ich das du wirklich was sagen leute
lasst einfach auf sich warten
[Musik]
video mit diesem bild hier abschied ich
möchte wieder gefeiert wird in kalabrien
zufällig gesagt das video abchecken und
abdi wird auf jeden fall die push
notifications gemacht hat nur das
gemacht habe kommentierte wir uns jetzt
mit anderen krieg den zaun nächsten
video erläutert weil ich bin raus